Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Niccolò Porcellato
In molte famiglie avvengono fatti
che cambieranno le relazioni
interne ad esse.
Io oggi vorrei parlarvi di uno di questi.
Molti anni fa mio fratello,
di cinque anni più grande di me,
fu travolto da un'onda
che lo portò lontano.
I suoi pensieri e la sua personalità
non furono più gli stessi di prima
e fu molto difficile comunicare con lui.
Da allora la mia famiglia ebbe un trauma
e lui un dolore profondo.
Molti anni dopo, perciò,
ho deciso di capirci di più,
capire di più dei problemi della mente,
capire di più di queste malattie.
Allora mi sono unita a un gruppo
di persone interessate e abbiamo formato
un'associazione,
l'associazione progetto Itaca.
L'associazione progetto Itaca
ha come obiettivi
il supporto e l'attivazione
di progetti che prevengano,
che informino e che aiutino
le persone con le malattie mentali
e anche aiutino le loro famiglie.
Allora ci siamo detti:
cerchiamo di capirne di più,
cerchiamo di capire
cosa vuol dire la salute mentale,
che entità ha, che tipo di problemi sono.
Ci siamo imbattute in dati
estremamente rilevanti.
Vi farò vedere solamente
uno di questi dati,
spero di non terrorizzarvi.
Quando qua parliamo di disturbi mentali,
vedo delle mani alzate, quando parliamo
di disturbi mentali,
qua parliamo di disturbi più lievi,
ansia, quella che ho io adesso,
attacchi di panico,
fino a malattie conclamate
più invalidanti.
Allora ci siamo dette:
ma come mai se questi problemi
sono così enormi,
se i numeri sono così significativi,
non se ne parla di più,
non se ne sa di più di questi problemi?
Abbiamo capito
che attorno alla malattia mentale
c'è un tappo che si chiama
“silenzio”, “stigma”.
Perché? Perché queste malattie
non si vedono
come un osso rotto,
dove si fa una radiografia
e immediatamente si vede dov'è la frattura
e si può ingessare.
Sono malattie nascoste,
sono malattie che fanno paura,
fanno vergogna (perché
stiamo parlando di persone diverse,
di persone non allineate,
e sappiamo che le persone diverse
fanno paura.
Però ci siamo anche detti
“cerchiamo di capirci ancora di più”.
Perché? Perché queste sono malattie
e come tutte le malattie vanno affrontate,
diagnosticate e curate.
Per cui abbiamo cercato,
non solo in Italia, ma nel mondo,
di capire quali sono
i progetti che più sono efficaci
per questi tipi di malattie
che sappiamo che sono,
appunto, una gamma molto ampia.
E ci siamo imbattuti
in un progetto bellissimo
che si chiama Fountain House.
È un progetto che è nato a New York
molti anni fa
e il suo primo fondatore ha spiegato così
il concetto alla base
di questa istituzione
“anche la persona che ha un solo mignolo
che ancora funziona, cioè la persona
che è schiacciata totalmente
dalla malattia,
ha la possibilità di lavorare
su questo mignolo.
Noi lavoreremo su quello, noi lavoreremo
sulla parte sana della persona,
mentre la parte malata viene tenuta fuori
dai lavori in parallelo, ovviamente,
dalla nostra Club House, così si chiamano
le nostre istituzioni, con i medici,
i professionisti,
gli psichiatri.
All'interno non c'è giudizio,
per la persona che sta male,
ma viene accompagnata
in un percorso che è quello
di ritrovare piano piano,
attraverso delle unità lavorative interne,
la sua capacità di avere una vita sociale
e eventualmente una vita lavorativa.
Di queste Club House
ce n'è moltissime al mondo,
più di trecento, qua vedete una pianta
dalla Corea fino al Canada,
dalla Russia fino all'Argentina,
e tutte sono coordinate
da Club House International,
che è l'agenzia che mantiene
uno standard molto alto,
mantiene la formazione e controlla,
con un processo peer to peer,
che queste funzionino
nella stessa maniera,
con l'attenzione alla persona.
Allora ci siamo detti “ma forse
possiamo portarlo anche noi in Italia”
e così sono nati dei Club Itaca italiani.
Qua vedete delle foto di Milano e di Roma
e nei momenti sia di unità lavorative
di cucina e di giardinaggio
e altri momenti più sociali.
Allora abbiamo capito
che per superare il silenzio
bisognava parlarne,
per cui ci siamo informati
e abbiamo cominciato
svariati altri progetti,
progetti di formazione,
sia specifici che generali,
progetti di autoaiuto importantissimo,
perché le persone che non stanno bene
e che hanno una difficoltà, una paralisi,
proprio, anche nell'agire,
nel poter parlare con gli altri,
possono parlare con gli altri,
abbiamo fatto un numero verde
e abbiamo fatto,
appunto, queste Club House.
Io ne ho viste moltissime
in giro per il mondo,
ho visto un ragazzo, per esempio,
che raccontava
“io ho cominciato a scivolare piano piano
verso l'isolamento, pensavo che gli altri,
che i dottori, che gli amici,
che i parenti fossero i malati,
invece il malato ero io
e questo l'ho capito solamente
quando sono entrato nella Club House
ed è ricominciato il mio percorso
di attivare le mie capacità”.
Un'altra ragazza invece, giovane,
una ragazza che voleva fare la ballerina
e lei diceva
“io avevo un dolore molto profondo
dentro di me, piangevo tutto il giorno,
mi chiudevo in bagno per piangere.
La decisione più importante della mia vita
è stata entrare in una Club House.
Oggi ho un piccolo appartamento,
un piccolo lavoro e degli amici”.
Questo vuol dire che è tornata
ad una vita di serenità,
di positività rispetto a quello
che era prima.
Tra gli altri progetti abbiamo,
come ho detto prima,
la famiglia è un asse centrale,
perché è la famiglia,
il primo anello attorno a cui
tutte le persone
che stanno male si appoggiano,
che viene scardinata da queste malattie.
Abbiamo fatto un bellissimo programma
che si chiama Family to family,
famiglia a famiglia,
un programma che insegna ai familiari
cos'è la malattia mentale, il rispetto
per la malattia,
il rispetto per il malato,
capire se non vogliono
prendere le medicine,
quali possono essere
le strategie che aiutano
affinché il malato possa prendere in mano
la sua vita e andare avanti
nel processo di cura.
Poi ci siamo imbattuti in un'altra realtà
che ci ha molto spaventato,
c'è un enorme 'gap',
c'è un buco tra il momento
in cui queste malattie sorgono,
in maniera spesso molto nascosta
e poco visibile,
al momento in cui viene fatta
la diagnosi e la cura,
come vedete tra gli otto e i dieci anni.
Otto e dieci anni
sono un periodo infinito,
voi provate a pensare ai tumori oggi,
lasciare un tumore per otto, dieci anni
senza curarlo è impensabile,
però alcuni anni fa
- dieci, quindici anni fa, non di più-
non si parlava neppure
del cancro, del tumore,
era, si diceva, “il brutto male”,
che cos'ha?
Una malattia che non si può
neanche nominare.
Ecco, noi vorremmo arrivare a che
le nostre malattie siano affrontate,
si possa sciogliere questa paura,
si possa sciogliere questo silenzio
e possano venire affrontate
come oggi è stato il cancro.
Naturalmente sono processi, di guarigione:
dal cancro si guarisce? si previene;
dal diabete si guarisce? si previene;
si convive molto bene, molta gente convive
con queste malattie, lo può dire,
anzi c'è molta empatia
verso queste malattie;
verso le nostre assolutamente no.
Poche settimane fa siamo state
a un congresso
a Bolzano, dove è stato molto interessante
vedere una diapositiva
di un grande ricercatore,
forse il primo padre della riabilitazione,
ecco qua parlando forse della malattia
più grave, più invasiva,
della schizofrenia,
lui dice che il numero di pazienti
che riprendono
la loro vita, che migliorano
sostanzialmente la qualità di vita,
lui lo fa con dei dati scientifici
molto forti,
sono tra il 40 e il 70% dei casi.
Noi stessi della nostra associazione
siamo rimasti stupiti di questo numero,
perché è un numero molto alto, per cui
parlarne è importante
e bisogna andare avanti.
In questa linea, diciamo,
il progetto Itaca
ha fatto il suo slogan
“parlare è il primo passo per uscirne”,
magari qualcuno di voi
l'ha visto alla televisione.
Poi abbiamo fatto uno spot
abbastanza provocatorio,
che si chiama “un minuto di rumore”.
Un minuto di rumore, con un'agenzia
che ci ha aiutato a metterlo insieme,
è stato una giornata, il dieci di ottobre
che è la giornata della salute mentale
in tutto il mondo,
siamo andati in giro per Milano
facendo rumore con campanelline,
con palloncini, e devo dire che è stato
molto bello perché tutto il web
ci ha ritornato dei video
che poi sono stati montati,
anzi abbiamo già vinto un premio
con questo video,
di ragazzi che scendevano le scale
battendo su delle bottiglie d'acqua
che si rompevano,
di altri che in ufficio battevano
con la calcolatrice,
di tutto, è tornato
e hanno montato un bellissimo video
che però è troppo lungo qua oggi
per farvelo vedere,
per cui invece vi farò vedere un attimo
quello che è successo per strada a Milano,
ed è invece un video
molto amatoriale, nostro
(musica)
un palloncino ed uno spillo,
e dire che se hanno pazienza
fanno un minuto di rumore
nella giornata mondiale
della salute mentale.
Fai vedere la maglietta!
(musica)
Oggi è la giornata mondiale
della salute mentale!
10 Ottobre. Progetto Itaca organizza
un flash mob in tutta Milano
(tamburi)
Attenti che scoppia!
[un minuto di rumore -
il primo passo è farsi sentire]
Mettiamo il palloncino sopra
la testa. Avete lo spillo?
Al mio tre, si scoppia tutti insieme.
Uno, due, tre!
(applausi)
Ciao, grazie.
C'era anche della musica,
c'era anche qualcosa
di meno rumoroso, devo dire che è stato
un grande ritorno anche per noi
di accompagnamento,
mentre - non di paura,
ma di accompagnamento.
Oggi il progetto Itaca
è in cinque città italiane,
abbiamo tantissime persone
che ci vogliono aiutare,
appunto non siamo più da soli,
siamo riusciti un pochettino
a sciogliere questa paura
e io vorrei che,
sono qua sul palco proprio
per chiedervi di aiutarci a far sì
che mai più nessuna persona
che ha una malattia mentale
o un suo familiare, debbano vergognarsi
di soffrire di queste malattie,
e vi voglio invitare a raggiungere
il nostro grande piccolo esercito
rumoroso di Itaca,
con il cuore per la mente.
Grazie.
(Applausi)